- Guys, Macaulay Culkin
is back, I'm so excited.
(audience cheers)
I know, it is not Home Alone
6, My Parents are now Deceased.
(audience laughs)
He is, (laughs)
They would be, they'd be
super old now, you guys,
they'd be super old.
- [Doug] Catherine
O'Hara is alive.
- What?
- Nothing.
(audience laughs)
- No, I mean, I'm not talking
about Catherine O'Hara,
I'm talking about the actual
family, The McCallisters,
because Home Alone was
a documentary, Doug.
(audience laughs)
But Macaulay Culkin is now
in a pizza-themed cover band
that just released the
premiere video on MUZU.TV.
Comedians, what is this
pizza-themed cover band called?
Is it A, The Red Hot
Chili Pepperonis?
B, The Pizza Underground?
C, The Mamas and the Papa Johns?
(bell rings)
(audience laughs)
Moshe Kasher.
- It happens to be B,
The Pizza Underground
because I have bought
every CD they've ever made,
which is not even one.
- [Chris] Well, that is
correct, The Pizza Underground
is the correct answer.
(cheers and applause)
It is a Velvet
Underground-themed
pizza cover band.
Do we have some video of that?
(kazoo music)
Lou Reed was so upset to not
have kazoo in the original
Walk on the Wild Side.
(laughs)
And, can I point out that
the big news about this video
is that Kevin McCallister
finally got his very
own cheese pizza.
(laughs and applause)
He's just playing
a kazoo through it.
- [Doug] And then he
decided to decorate with it?
(laughs)
- He didn't say he
was gonna eat it,
he just wanted to
put it on his face.
- [Doug] His band should be
called The Wet Bandits, I think.
(Chris laughs)
- [Chris] No, Doug,
that's not cool, man.
They tortured that kid,
that's why they sat on those
Christmas ornaments outside,
to ruin them.
Is this a good move for
Macaulay Culkin career-wise?
- Pizza on his face?
- Yeah!
(laughs)
- Well, I guess when
you put it that way.
It's an awesome idea.
- [Moshe] He went
from dating Mila Kunis
to just being a pizza
face, it's a good move.
- [Doug] Take that,
ya filthy animal